hearing is incredible think about it a
tiny little bit of tissue in your ear a
tenth of a millimeter thick moves in
response to changes in air pressure and
converts them into tiny vibrations in
fluid and then those get converted into
electric chemical impulses that go to
the brain where they are somehow decoded
into what you experience as sound and if
all of that is working properly then
you're able to pick out one source of
sound from another in 3d space and your
brain is optimized to pick out words and
language even through huge amounts of
noise it'll even filter out constant
steady noise like a fan or the wind
whistling through trees to give an idea
of just how difficult a task that is
this is the wave form of the sound
that's on this video the same
information just presented differently
but it's not something that you can make
sense of with your eyes and it's not
like your eardrum
only resonates at a few frequencies
human hearing in a healthy young person
runs from somewhere up around 20,000
cycles a second all the way down to 20
which means the eardrum can pick up air
movements with wavelengths that range
from a couple of centimeters for high
frequencies to 10 or 20 meters for
really low bass the sort of low rumbling
bass that you would get from say a jet
engine just over there is Amsterdam's
Schiphol Airport in terms of aircraft
flying in and out it's the busiest
airport in Europe six runways two
control towers one just for the new
runway that's over there that opened in
2003 that runway is five kilometers away
from the terminal if you look at aerial
photos you can see plane after plane
after plane lined up on a 15-minute taxi
including going on a bridge across a
road under Canal it was raining when my
plane landed but I just about got that
shot held the window
but there was one residential area just
back there well there was nothing but
flat ground between those houses and the
back end of jet engines I mean of course
it was flat ground it was the
Netherlands but there was one spot just
back there where it got significantly
louder for the people who lived there
and those local residents were not happy
of course the one day I'm here they're
actually landing on that runway not
taking off so the engines are pointed
the other way but the point still stands
local residents were not happy this is
the solution well not a solution but at
least something to help this is a park
that serves two purposes one to be land
art the sort of high concept big
sculpture that's created by moving
enormous amounts of Earth and rock this
was designed by an artist I mean at the
end of a drum to show you but you know
Airport but the second purpose is sound
dampening these ridges are metres apart
roughly very roughly around the same
wavelength as the low Rumble that you
get from a jet engine not exact of
course but in the same order of
magnitude close enough to be disruptive
so rather than the sound waves just
rolling over the land instead they're
scattered in all directions up and away
not onwards not perfectly not even close
but enough to bring the noise level at
those houses back down within acceptable
limits
the architects claim that one of the
inspirations for this was people
noticing that the engine noise sounded
quieter when the fields were plowed
because yes your brain can filter out
constant steady noise it can even over
time get used to filtering out
intermittent loud noise is like living
next to an airport but that filtering
job is a lot easier if the noise would
just be a little less loud
you